the Senate Intelligence Committee here
is new testimony this morning and its
investigation of Russian interference in
the 2016 election committee leaders say
their probe will be thorough independent
and fair they gave reporters an
eye-opening look at some of the evidence
they are studying on the other side of
the Capitol the house investigation is
stuck with members arguing over
committee chairman David newness and his
relationship with the White House Jeff
'begaze is on Capitol Hill with a
stunning claim from the Senate
committees top Democrat Jeff good
morning good morning the Senate hearing
today will likely start with fewer
fireworks in last week's house hearing
there aren't a lot of big names on the
witness list but what it will do is seek
to expose what US officials believe was
the Kremlin's goal here and that is to
[ __ ] the 2016 election an outside
foreign adversary effectively sought to
hijack our most critical democratic
process the election of a president the
Senate committee is reviewing thousands
of documents including raw intelligence
they've requested interviews with 20
people among them the president's
son-in-law and senior White House
adviser jared kushner we will always say
to you this investigation scope will go
wherever the intelligence leads it both
Republican Senator Richard burr and the
top Democrat on the committee Mark
Warner said that they will use subpoenas
if necessary as they investigate Russian
actions we will get to the bottomless
the two men stood side by side as they
vowed to work as a bipartisan unit he
usually knows my sources before I do and
he's let me assure you I've also got his
cell phone butchers mangie here some me
more than he sometimes like while the
house investigation remains stalled and
in disarray there is no timetable for
hearings after last week's testimony
from FBI director James Comey all I can
tell you is what we're investigating
which includes whether there was any
coordination between people associate of
the Trump campaign and the Russians the
embattled chairman of the House
Committee Devon Nunez is still resisting
calls to recuse himself amid accusations
that he's trying to shield the Y
house guys there's nothing there's
nothing to report I appreciate that the
attention now but thank you senators
Warner and burrs say their investigation
will be fair and impartial senator
McCarran have you have you personally
coordinated with the White House at all
on the scope of this investigation and
how do you prevent it from going off
track no sir I have not and it's the
relationship and the trust we have and
that will be tested during the course of
this process they say their
responsibility here is to produce a
bipartisan report that exposes the
extent of Russian interference not only
here but in Europe as well Nora all
right Jeff thank you so much